This episode is sponsored by MyHeritage which
helps you discover your family history and origins.
To check out MyHeritage, click the link in
the description for a 14-day free trial.
And if you decide to continue your subscription,
you’ll get a 50% discount.
For an activity that mostly
involves sitting and staring,
microscopy is a surprisingly high stakes task.
On the other side of the lens
are drops full of potential,
a multitude of worlds to unravel and examine.
But they’re also fragile worlds, easy to
fracture and lose with just a tiny slip of the hand.
The stakes only get higher when you’re dealing
with an organism like this Dactylochlamys pisciformis,
a creature so rare that it’s only been
reported a few times since it was
first discovered in 1901.
This was one of those rare sightings, a
clip we showed in a previous episode because
we were so excited to find something so unlikely.
Watching it swim around on its own, oblivious
to our presence, it seems like this is what
spotting a solitary tiger in the wild would
feel like.
Distant, unique, and all the more precious
for its rarity.
But one day, our singular microbial friend
vanished without a trace, leaving a trail
of mysteries and inspiration in its wake.
Finding this one Dactylochlamys pushed James,
our master of microscopes, to try and find more.
So he went back to the spot where he’d found
it, sampling the same waters over and over
again so that he had drops and drops to sift
and sort through for hundreds of hours on end.
But for months, nothing turned up,
until finally, one did.
The sight had James’ hands shaking with
excitement.
It’s one thing to put so much work into
finding a rare organism.
But the reality of success, that’s something
else altogether.
And all of those feelings, the thrill of
discovery, the satisfaction of work paying
off, they were, in this case, also interlaced
with the fragility of what James had found.
On the one hand, he wanted to be able to watch
it live its life and record those moments,
capture them so that its morphology and behavior
could be etched into a vivid record for scientists
to study and draw conclusions from.
But video is risky.
To be able to see so deeply into the organism,
James has to watch it with the objective close
to the sample, which leaves room for only
a thin layer of water
for the Dactylochlamys to survive in.
And sometimes, they don’t survive, which
means we would lose both the organism and
the possibility of learning more about it.
We’d already lost one Dactylochlamys, we
didn’t want to lose another.
So James was very, very careful, transferring
the ciliate from the larger sample to a slide
and then gently covering it with the coverslip.
He added a drop of immersion oil to the coverslip
and dipped his best microscope objective into the oil.
And then he pressed record, gathering around
25 minutes in the life of a rare microbe.
In 1901, Robert Lauterborn, the German biologist
who discovered Dactylochlamys pisciformis, gave
what is perhaps the best description of the
organism, saying “…it is one of the most
bizarre and striking microbes I know….”
And he’s right.
This might be a strange reference to make
for an organism we were excited to find, but
there’s something about this Dactylochlamys
that resembles a lopsided Eye of Sauron.
It’s that combination of the elongated shape,
the large round contractile vacuole on the
posterior side of its body, and the clutter
of structures that project
out like the spikes of a fire.
Maybe a better comparison is this Actinobolina,
another ciliate that we’ve talked about on this channel.
For the actinobolina, those tentacle-like
spikes have a clear purpose.
They help the organism trap food and feed.
So perhaps the Dactylochlamys uses its own
spikes for a similar purpose.
But until we see them in action, we won’t
know for sure.
But James also noticed something
when he was comparing
this second Dactylochlamys to the
first one he found.
They didn’t quite look the same.
There were subtle differences in their macronucleus
and cilia and other parts that made him think
that maybe they’re different organisms, that
maybe the organism he found last year was
actually not a Dactylochlamys pisciformis,
but actually a related species called
Dactylochlamys hystriz that was discovered in 1928
and then never found again, until James.
Because both of these species
have been so difficult to find,
their descriptions are sparse and incomplete.
So for now, we believe that the first one
that James found was Dactylochlamys hystriz,
and the second one was a Dactylochlamys pisciformis.
And James is working on uncovering as much
as he can with the tools we have today.
When both Dactylochlamys pisciformis and Dactylochlamys
hystriz were discovered, the ability to study
them at the genetic level wasn’t available yet.
But this is a different era, and James was
careful with his Dactylochlamys pisciformis
in part so he could study its DNA.
But the stakes were still high, and so he
still needed to be careful.
He took the slide with the coverslip on top
and floated it in water, letting him carefully
remove the coverslip without killing the precious
organism inside.
Then, he needed to clean the Dactylochlamys
to make sure there was nothing else that might
contaminate his sample and affect his results.
So he used a pipette to grab the organism
and move it over to a clean drop of water,
and then again to another drop.
And then one more, to one last drop before
storing it in a tiny tube in his freezer.
From there, this frozen Dactylochlamys will
have part of its DNA sequenced, revealing
the genes that make it the way it is and maybe
even uncovering some of its closest microbial relations.
And that’s only the beginning.
The first two Dactylochlamyses that James found
took a tremendous amount of time and patience.
But in the last four months, he’s found
more than twenty of them!
Twenty!
That’s not a huge number by microbe discovery
standards, where the rapid reproduction means
that you can sometimes stumble on colonies
of hundreds of a single organism.
But for any dactylochlamys species, twenty
is windfall.
Some of them have been frozen for their own
DNA studies, while others have been put under
the microscope for James to watch.
And sometimes he sees something new, like
this species that might be Dactylochlamys
hystriz, and that seems to have extended its
tail out.
Other times, the things he finds are very
new—like “new species” new.
When you zoom in, you can see how similar
yet distinct it is from the other species we’ve seen.
But it will still be some time before we know
enough to know whether it really is a new species.
In the meantime though, the fact that we’ve
found more of these Dactylochlamyses means
that we have more chances to learn more about
them.
Because sure, finding a rare organism is thrilling.
But even more thrilling is the chance to make
it a little less rare.
The stakes of finding one may be lower, but
that doesn’t lessen the joy of discovery,
of having made something feel more
common and realizing it is still precious.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to MyHeritage for sponsoring
this episode.
If the prospect of building a family tree
has felt intimidating to you in the past,
MyHeritage makes it easier, Using MyHeritage,
you can search for and find historical records
of your family and ancestors easily and you might
even discover new relatives in the process.
The site not only gives you powerful tools
to reconnect with your family history, they
also have advanced AI technologies that you
can use to restore, colorize,
and enhance old family photos.
Their Deep Nostalgia tool even lets you create
a short animation of the faces in your photos.
MyHeritage is the #1 family history service
in Europe, and has over 16+ billion records
for you to explore.
And right now, you can sign up for a 14-day
free trial and enjoy all the features MyHeritage
has to offer at the link in the description,
and if you decide to continue your subscription,
you’ll get a 50% discount.
We’d also like to thank each and every person
whose name is on the screen right now.
These are some of our Patreon patrons, and
without them, and all of our other patrons
whose names aren’t on the screen right now,
this channel could not exist.
So thank you again to all of them, and all
of you for watching and supporting this channel.
If you’d like to join our patreon community,
you can do so over at patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you’d like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes James Weiss, you can check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram
And if you’d like to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.